so when I tried to kill myself I took
about 100 ders and I really thought that
would do it I wrote a note the whole
thing and then when I woke up wait wait
so so you you were were you at home
alone I was at home alone I kicked my
husband out I like fabricated a fight
and kicked him out of the house and I
just thought okay and I in my mind I
really genuinely thought he's just going
to be better off without me you know
he's probably I'm in a lot of trouble
and I felt like I've had a good life
I've accomplished some really good stuff
this has been a good run
and it was all the pills talking but um
I was just convinced it was my time to
go so you took a hundred downers yes and
then what happened you black out right
away I blacked out and the worst part
about trying to kill yourself is waking
up cuz I woke up and I was like you are
[__] kidding me in fact that was the
first thing I said my hand of God when I
woke up I you [__] kidding me in your
house yes and there was like blood on
the sheets and I didn't know what
happened it turns out I had taken a fall
and you know it was and also just so you
know I've never had a drink in my life
you don't drink no never had a drink in
my life because no because my parents
were
alcoholics I think I thought I couldn't
become a pill addict because I don't
drink like oh I mustn't be an addict I
don't even drink and you know when I was
taking the pills like I said I felt like
they were very justified in my mind so
you wake up there's blood all over the
bed and I'm alone in the house and
you're alone in the house him and Kanye
are not coming over and I were the
neighbors still they were neighbors they
kept to themselves they did no but um
and yeah I I then called two doctors and
I said I tried to take my life I took a
bunch of pills I don't want to die
anymore but I think I legit in injured
myself so can I come in and get some
x-rays or something and so um I went to
the hos the emergency room how um I I
called my husband husband and he drove
me and first we went to the doctor's
office and he wisely said oh we can't do
that x-ray here you've got to go to the
hospital and you know I were you
bleeding um I probably wasn't bleeding
but I had like lacerations and bruises
and stuff and I didn't know if IID like
Twisted an ankle or something like that
and so um I I went in and I told the
doctors exactly what I had done and
taken and I didn't know just by telling
them that they have to put you on a
psych hold right and so I was still
probably a little bit messed up and I
remember saying to the doctor like okay
well this is great thank you for you
know the saline I'm fine I'm going to
head out and he was like no no you're
GNA stay you know and um I said no no
I'm good and then I go just I'm not
gonna do this but what if I just like
pulled out the IV I'm just asking and he
pulled back the curtain and he's like
see those two cops they put the
bracelets on you and I will never forget
that expression the bracelets the
handcuffs and so I was in The Nut bin
for 3
days